hello everybody this is grandmaster
varakovian and we're gonna do
some really insane in the endgame
positions today
so we had a little technical issues but
we're gonna survive
and we're gonna do some really insane
today
okay okay okay
all right uh okay guys so now the first
position i have for you okay
first position right to play
okay right to play and draw can you find
the right idea here
how you can try to make a draw in this
complicated position here
it looks like position is really bad for
white it looks like kaput you know
it looks like a put here actually sorry
i gotta click this
and start because you're gonna lose the
d-pawn and then the c pawn is gonna
march through it looks completely busted
you know it just looks like it's just
gonna be over
it's an easy cut victory here but what
you're gonna do
here how are you gonna come up with
something to defend this
so i wanna give you a couple of minutes
to think okay then i'm gonna check the
chat to see if you're finding this
solution okay
so you have couple of minutes to think
here to come up with a creative idea
okay all right
my mic i'm gonna lower it loud now is it
is it better now
is it not too loud guys all right
hopefully it's okay now
hopefully so again
incredible positions where you have to
come up with the really powerful ideas
to get the win so what would be the idea
i'm gonna check the chat really quick to
see if we have some solutions here
all right so we have some solutions here
we have the chat here people watching
uh hello akobia hello everybody
greetings everybody hello all the older
students and fans who are watching this
so king f3 is a suggestion here
okay uh king f3
so let's take a look king f3 followed by
king g4 okay but you have to look at the
defenses right
you have to look at defenses guys i mean
if you play king f3 what's gonna happen
is it really just gonna give you the
game no
all right king f3 so if he plays
if he plays 95 then we simply go here
okay and now the threat is king d4
to win a pawn if you play king f6
then simply bishop goes to d5
now with the idea of king d4 and simply
pick up the pawn
on c4 so if k7
king d4
king d6 bishop c4 bishop f2 check i have
king c3 so you take and this is just
going to be a draw two pieces
can never win against the bishop okay so
two pieces cannot win
against the bishop
okay so that's one idea so what else we
can do
so now we start after three but now
we're gonna meet
this move king f5 and now this is the
best defense here guys and if you play
skinny f5
what are you going to do how are you
gonna try to make a draw in this
in this position here
the bishop is blocked and now he wants
to take on d2
so it's pretty clear what you got to do
you don't have too many options so king
e2 attacking the bishop
bishop h4
and now again if he consolidates with
the king on d4 it's just going to be
winning so you have to take measures
against this
and go here now 95
again it seems like this extra pawn
extra piece advantage
and looks like it's almost consolidated
now
it's almost consolidated but now you're
going to play a strong move here
how how are you going to do this now
you have to try to eliminate the c pawn
so let's say if you try this
unfortunately you're gonna run into
bishop b7 and you go here bishop goes
here
and now you you cannot get
closer you cannot get closer so actually
probably
sorry this line i showed you is actually
a problem guys
because of bishop c4 takes and king b3
and white is winning one of the pieces
so it's going to be a draw but the other
line
um so here in this line you can play
bishop to here
and bishop a5 and this way you cannot
get closer
to the pawn
so so what is the other idea here we
have
other alternative for white let's see
here guys what do we have
king e3 okay
k3 is definitely a possibility k3 with
the idea to get on d4 right
i like this suggestion king e3 correct
trying to get a king on d4 that is the
idea
uh so k3
then he plays bishop d8
idea to get the bishop to b6 so
now you're walking in d4
bishop check you go here
bishop check now he was king d4 it looks
like
great we are about to achieve a draw
here guys
we are about to achieve the draw because
we're going to win the c4 pawn
right it looks like that now it comes
the trick c3 sacrificing the pawn and if
you capture
it's going to be a checkmate bishop v8
okay
c3 and bishop b6 and you cannot go to c4
knight takes it d3 takes it so you
cannot do anything
okay
so now
now what you're gonna do after this move
there's there's only one way now for you
to make a draw here
if you take you're gonna lose if you
play d3 he's gonna push c2
and now i am sure you guys have the
solution here i'm gonna quickly look at
the chat
bishop e4 check bravo guys bravo bishop
e4
check getting the d5 square for the king
bishop d4 check if he goes away you can
take and say thank you very much
if he goes check you go king d5 you have
a nice you know it's just a draw
if you go back here in this position if
he goes here
if you take again again it's a mate here
the king is getting made it cannot go
anywhere okay
cannot go anywhere and do anything so he
he's losing here
so he has to go
so what we have to do after he goes to
e6 guys what are we going to do
in this position
what are we going to do here if we take
there's a bishop b6 made
so we cannot do that so we have to do
what
continuously give a check okay
continuously give a check
in this position to be able to get that
square okay so we have to do that
bishop d5 and if he goes away and
you know if he goes there you can even
take actually because now you have the
e4 square
access okay and if it doesn't do that if
it goes here
then you just you know again if you take
it's made so you just give a perpetual
here you take check
this all right very good guys
any questions any questions you have
about this position everybody got it
yeah you just gotta keep checking here
to get that light square
and if he checks you have the king d5
all right very good guys we're gonna
move on to the next position okay
some more intense end games like this
for you okay
i have today where it looks like it's
very
unlikely very unlikely but you're gonna
be able to come up with
ideas to try to save the game like this
one this one i liked a lot because it
was
not easy okay let's look at this
position here
white to play
and win
these are very difficult studies from
that same book i used last week okay
from the casparian casparian uh
okay so it's why to play
and when so again i'm going to give you
a couple of minutes to think
so you can find the solution okay
and i'll take a look at the chat
okay
all right so i can see the chat now guys
so okay so this is the next position
here
why to play and win
how can you try to win this
all right
so i gave you a couple of minutes to
think and you can type in the chat your
answer so i would like to see your
answers here okay
again it's not going to be very simple
or straightforward okay
you have to expect that it's going to be
some some complications okay
think think think a little bit more guys
try to get into the position as much as
you can okay
as much as you can
okay all right let's take a look at the
chat here guys see what you have here
so a lot of you are saying bishop f6 and
just wins
you guys claiming it's a win but it's
not so simple yet guys you have to go
deeper okay
i know you're saying this one this is
correct first move okay
you got the first one but you have to
realize
you're saying it's over here but it's
not really over yet i have this move
guys
yeah if i go here it is over i agree
with you you take here and it's over
but i'm not going to do that i'm going
to go here
and now the question is this is where
everything starts okay
this is where it begins even here
okay so what do we do now
very important move here if you have to
play
very very important move
always remember sometimes you have to
find those silent moves okay
those quiet moves you have to find the
silent move the quiet moves
to do it okay so remember about remember
about that okay
all right what do we have the rook is
always under a threat correct we must
move the bishop i guess well if you move
the bishop but then he moves the knight
and knight f5 or something
guys think calculate as much as you can
okay
you have to calculate as much as you can
okay uh rook f7 correct
that's the correct move down now we're
threatening bishop takes e7
so there are a couple of options if he
plays knight c6
what do we do now how do we win after
knight c6 guys
that's okay that's okay akiva this is
the hard positions okay that's why i'm
giving you time to think okay
this is a high level stuff you're doing
here this is not a you know
white to play and win or maintain three
made in four made in five position this
is a high level of training in endgames
okay
that is going to help you improve your
imagination your calculation
okay that's why you do studies to
improve those factors over your game
okay
calculation imagination okay
now
bishop takes bishop
now he takes back
could you could you take advantage of
the awkwardness
awkward position of this knight on the
eighth how could you do it
how could you do that
yes and looks like patrick dally has it
patrick has it attacked the knight
and now the knight cannot go on b7 we
take f7 we take and if he goes here
skewer winning denied okay
end the game if he goes here even better
fork winning the knight perfect
so that solves the problem he cannot
play 96 but what if he's
trying to do this move king g6 continues
to put pressure on the rook
and now we have no choice if we take
he's going to take the rook and with the
lone bishop you cannot check mate okay
this is going to be a draw
so you have no choice you have to play
rook f8 okay
you have to play rook f8
and now block is completely stuck it
looks like he cannot move the bishop you
take
he moves the knight you take so he has
to go here
knight c6
only move bishop takes and now he goes
king g7
king g7 attacking the rook okay
attacking the rook and if the root goes
away he's gonna win the bishop
so continue guys continue thinking now
what are you going to do
what do we do here guys
what can we do here
rookie ain't correct but angus here
looks like he's just gonna know you you
your rook until you lose
you lose your bishop here he's just
gonna keep attack our
rook until we move away and he takes our
bishop and then
bishop sorry knight versus rook it's
going to be a draw
it looks like it right it looks like
going to be a theoretical draw
what can you do though what can you do
here
all right what do we have here ryan ryan
ellis
ryan ellis okay shade kill on educate
shade
okay chad hillary yeah absolutely guys
everybody good job okay rook had now he
continues with this kg7
and again if we move away he's gonna
take so what is the winning move here
where is the winning move here guys to
win this game
i want you to use your imagination okay
use your imagination to find this okay
how are you gonna do that
how you're going to do that okay
bishop f6 fantastic yes check
he has to take and now
that is your solution guys that is that
pretty
solution at the end where you just do a
little skewer
and picking up that night bravo brother
guys
excellent job okay this is a heavy
difficult study okay
but you managed to solve it of course we
we made some moves to make it a little
bit easier for you the best way is to
solve everything
without the moving the pieces but it's
not easy i understand it's hard
but you did a great job okay everybody
nicely done okay
and now we are moving forward for the
next position okay
very good you're doing excellent guys
now we're gonna do some more positions
where it looks like
it's game over okay it looks like your
game is over
but you're gonna try to break through so
so let's see here
next endgame study okay
so same same setup guys i'm going to
give you a couple of minutes to think
and try to calculate as deep as you can
okay as
deep as possible so you can find the
solution okay
all right white to play guys
why to play and draw okay
right to play and draw
so the problem we're facing here is
we're losing our bishop okay
bishop is gone okay the bishop is gone
we know that okay so we have to figure
out
how can we construct some kind of a
mechanism okay
drawing mechanism in this position okay
whether it's some kind of a
uh you know perpetual ideas so you have
to think of it okay
you have to think of the plan here
yeah this is this is incredible study
okay
the whole thing is seven moves deep okay
the whole thing is seven moves guys so
take your time
take your time and try to calculate okay
uh optic optic red panda what's what was
your question
type your question for the last one i'll
try to answer your question for the last
one but right now let's focus on this
one okay you can ask me your question
though
yeah this is this is a tough one guys
but again when you're solving these
positions you have to think
you're you have to think about it okay
use the imagination okay
okay um
i'm looking at the chat here i'm not
seeing the solution yet guys you've been
throwing a lot of moves out there but
not uh not accurately so far okay
so you have been throwing some answers
there but not as accurate yet
okay as i like
okay now we're getting some answers we
are getting some answers here
and i think we're getting closer now
we're getting closer at least we got the
first one guys perfect
king c2 there were a couple of uh you
know
people who found this that was that was
excellent okay excellent
king c2 is your start
let's establish this he has to take back
with the bishop okay
if he takes with this move then we
simply go knight c3
we attacking the rook and a bishop
and remember knight versus rook with no
pawns is a pretty much
always a draw okay if he goes here you
simply attack
and pick up the bishop if he goes here
then we simply take if he takes
then we have to draw okay so this will
be a draw the only way you lose is if
you go to the corner okay just don't go
in the corner stay in the middle with
the
knight and king next to each other you
should be able to make a draw here okay
you've got to stay with the king and the
knight now
so he's going to take back with the
bishop okay that's the only way he can
try to play for a win
now this is where it gets interesting
what do we do
king b2 obviously obvious choice
anything else you do he's going to take
your knight
so this is obvious choice okay now he
goes rook a4
activating the rook and putting pressure
on the knight
activating and putting pressure
now now what to do
because if you take the bishop you're
going to lose the knight
if you go here you're going to get
checked
and then if you go to a1 i move if you
go here i think he just simply wins with
rook b8
b7 bishop f5 and wins the pawn
okay so what are we gonna do here this
is the critical moment here
this is a critical moment and you have
to play
you must play precisely okay here
you simply have to play precisely here
so what is the idea guys i don't see it
i don't see it yet okay
i don't see it yet guys
d7 okay that is a suggestion by patrick
patrick what's the follow-up you're
suggesting the move that's fine but
what's the follow-up
knight c5 i see a suggestion with knight
c5
guys knight c5 uh
i don't know knight c5 look before how
is this gonna work
ah king c3 i guess but but then he goes
away
how is this gonna work his king is too
close guys
his king is too close
so i don't know i don't see how this is
gonna work right now
b7 he goes king e7
uh okay and if you go
here you stay with the bishop i think
bishop f5
is going to work here just king comes in
here and surrenders
surrenders the pawn okay and wins it
surrenders the pawn and wins it so now
guys
so the correct move here is d7 suggested
by one of you here now you're
threatening to play d8 queen
there is no time to take the knight
black is forced okay
black is simply forced now
to play the move king e7 okay so but
when he puts the king on a7 now
the position of the king is not very
good because there will be some strong
potential some strong potential force
here guys in this position
now what do you do here
at the end you'll be smiling when you
solve this position you will be smiling
like me like me at the end because it's
just
absolutely beautiful position okay
you will be you will be pretty shocked
at the end when this happens
the solution
knight c3 knight c3 we have the correct
solution
the pedro bono correct knight c3
attacking the rook
and the bishop so he has no choice
has to play rook before check anything
else you pick up the bishop okay
knight f6 somebody suggested knight f6
and that is
patrick dolly akiva knight f6 guys
knight f6
i'm not obliged to take i'll just bring
it here and take with my bishop i'm not
obliged to take the knight okay
i'm not gonna take that so then i win
so i win the game so knight c3
rook b4 check only move for block
and now what do you do
king a1 now the bishop is under attack
bishop is under attack and you're also
threatening the fantastic move knight d5
knight d5 is in the works as well guys
so he plays bishop before
thinking that he has secured this square
and next he's gonna simply pick up the
pawn
and it's going to be a draw it's going
to be a draw here
but the question is what can you do what
you can do
in this position guys again you have to
keep that imagination on okay
when you're doing this positions keep
that imagination on
so you can find the solution
still mate still mate okay how how
you're saying still made but how you
gonna make it work guys
and now i see the solutions are coming
bravo guys
bravo knight d5 check sacrificing the
knight
now threatening to take the rook as well
and the queen he has to take
and now we are going to
do what
we are going to do what now guys to have
this
d8 promotion he takes
and guess what still made guys still
made okay
that's what's gonna happen here okay
amazing study i agree
can't yeah absolutely unbelievable i
always enjoy doing this guys and this
is once again when i grew up when i grew
up and i was
trying to get better this i did a lot of
these studies okay
a lot of endgame stuff this in fact this
studies i'm doing i show you this book
last time
it's from 1982 okay 1982 very old book
okay
so these studies are from there and
they're composed by the best composers
okay
so these are people who they're not even
very strong players but they're very
strong
composers that they can compose these
positions okay
very good amazing these problems are
from a russian book from 1982 casparian
best studies
and i'm fluent in russian so i can read
and translate and i can set it up
i can read the notation in russian so i
haven't been able to find this
you know in english version there is
something similar
kasparian end game studies but it's not
really
like this this is a this one has
uh i think uh yeah it's about uh
and if you translate it's called
beautiful studies okay
a tudy all right
casparian was a world champion in uh
casparian was a world champion
in uh this studies you know
yes in a competitive in in in studies uh
composers and
so he was very good it's possible
absolutely
ryan wants to pick up some russian
very useful very few you know bobby
fischer was learning russian
but he was i don't know if you guys know
about this but bobby fischer was
learning russian
when you know when he was competing
against the soviets you know he wanted
to know what they
talk and he wanted to be able to read
the russian literature you know
so he actually i don't know how well he
learned but he i know he was studying
russian
to learn all right guys we're gonna move
forward okay
yeah this is the 80s 80s 90s training of
the soviet
chess school absolutely and that's where
i'm taking you guys
your end game level to that soviet chess
school of training okay
all right next okay
this one is white to play and win
okay
all right there we go
another complex another difficult
position white
to play and win okay
so if we take his rook he's gonna take
our rook and
so it's not so simple
this one is a little bit easier than the
previous one
this one is only five moves guys i want
to see who can give me the whole five
moves
okay so when you send your lines i want
you to give me
the whole thing
think
well it seems too easy uh but it's you
have to go deeper
yeah if you're thinking it's just root
b3 check not so simple okay
there is a good defense there is
incredible defense
in this position okay so what is the
idea
what is the idea
okay i need five moves here guys five
moves
okay we're getting there we're getting
there i'm seeing some solutions okay
sensing sensan has it since sam has it
but you need to go all the way since
then
you got to go all the way with the
solution since then
you're almost there but not quite
there's one more move missing at the end
you only got four moves in that line
okay
since then
yeah no i know but rook b3 is going to
be met by rook b6 okay
rook b3 is going to be met by a more
resilient
that's correct also since then you got
that one no in your first line in the
first line there's one more move at the
end
since then
and your first line you suggested
so okay i'm going to put this on so
obviously guys if you go here this is
game over
so his defense is going to be consists
of rp6
okay
you're gonna have to take no choice and
then here king a7 you can even play
rookie six
since then you have even this okay so
the the difficulty is this
and now the bishop is hanging and if you
take the bishop you lose the rook
so that's a draw and if you go here
guess what that's going to be a draw as
well you lose the bishop
so you have to figure out an idea here
what to do here
to put him into that winning position
you know rookie six uh king d7 i just
showed
rookie 6 i have king d7
bishop d8 correct absolutely now he has
to take
then
look ba check correct he goes away you
take the bishop so he has to go here to
protect it
he has to go here to protect the bishop
and now what do we do
once he goes there now what do we do
here guys
if you work in g8 he has bishop h6 he's
escaping
and he also can go king f7 to escape
okay
so you cannot let that happen you have
to do something here
what can you do guys king g6
absolutely bravo bravo
guys king g6 absolutely and the king
moves away
king is in a suk savank he moves away
thank you very much okay
he cannot do anything if he goes bishop
g7 i take it if he goes here i take it
as well
absolutely clear advantage and white
wins
perfect okay not as difficult as the
previous one but once again let's go
over this
incredible study check cause uptake
just wins so he's not gonna do that he's
gonna try to be more resilient with this
take here he just goes rookie six so
it's winning
so has to go here
take what takes that doesn't work so we
have to go for it
bishop d8 takes check
goes here and now simply king six
escapes we should play six that could be
a problem
so he goes king g6 and he escapes all
right
yeah i recommend you guys you know you
can do this
when i'm setting it up you can set it up
as well okay
you can you can you can set it up on
your uh
board as well or chessboard if you have
or you can do it on the
the computer
uh i'll have to analyze after why rk6
doesn't work
then draw seven which moment row k6
dendra
okay six okay six which comment
here
look
yeah just take dendra check and now king
d6 he defends
i don't know oh here okay well he
defends the bishop
okay so that's that's gonna be a draw
all right
okay guys we're gonna do one more okay
one more
incredible one okay all right
this one is a more practical position
okay
this one is a more practical position
so
this is white to play
white to play and draw guys
uh the problem is this pawn on d file is
really really advanced and uh and our
king is really far away so it looks at
the task it's going to be very difficult
here okay
our task it's going to be very difficult
our task it's going to be very very
difficult so what to do
our task is going to be very difficult
so what can we do here
white to play and draw this looks like a
real
endgame position i mean this could
really happen in your game okay
so you have to
you have to really calculate here
basically
so what's the first move
oh look at one you don't want to do
because you make my king closer
you're making my king come closer to my
pawn you know
and that's that's exactly what i want i
want to be closer
so you don't want to waste time giving
me a check
because i will be i will be get closer
okay
so you gotta figure out the path that
you can get to d2 quickly
you got to figure out the path that you
can do it
uh
all right what do we have the first move
here let's see
yeah rookie one also yeah he plays b2
yeah uh
no rook g3 has rook b8 ideas
rg3 rp8
oops sorry
i can just go here and push the b pawn
okay
so that doesn't work
all right so
so what's the idea i still don't see the
solution yet guys i still don't see the
solution yet
yeah rp1 is rook to b8 yeah
wait rook p1
how do you win the race here you say
wins the race but how do you win the
race here your king gets
and now you go here i cut you off and
this is a classical
classical lucena position okay
this would be a classical lucena
position
yeah i don't think we win the race here
guys
all right king g5 finally we getting
there here we go we start the march
okay kg5 this is correct the only way
to do it okay everything else loses
if he plays b2 then we attack
and then we get closer and we're going
to be able to
gobble up the pawn okay and now king c3
and just take if he goes here
go away and we take
okay
so he's not gonna do that he's gonna try
to go here with his king
e7 now
we go king f4 we it's a race so we gotta
get our king
in he gets here now king c5
king d2 king b4
and now it looks up we we we tried you
know
we tried we got close to it but we're
losing the race because
he's you know if we check now he's gonna
go here
we cannot go to the background because
he has a rook a1 check
winning uh you know winning the rook
right
so unfortunately it looks like we did
all this work you know for nothing all
this work for nothing guys because we're
not gonna be able to
hold this game but the question is
maybe we don't have something incredible
here okay maybe we don't have to give up
here
this is correct guys and you still have
a draw here
you have an incredible draw here
improbable draw here
you have to find it no guys if you go
rook g7 unfortunately
this is losing this is a classical
lucena position i've done videos several
videos on this okay
this is classical lucena this is winning
once your king gets cut
i'm sorry this is winning okay
so that's not gonna work so what can you
do here
now i'm seeing some solutions siddhant
satow sacrificing a rook siddhant
siddhant that's your rook
still mate she don't yes she don't gets
it correct
pedro bono the pedro bono also gets it
now check guys
you go here and now he takes your rook
and look at this
incredible still mate at the end okay
absolutely and the king
cannot go anywhere
and now it's everything is taken so
cannot go here
cannot go here and it's a steel mate
all right once again let's do this again
guys
let's do this again so go here that
loses
so we have to begin with the race
okay we start walking
that loses because of he's going to play
rook c8
now here you have to make sure c
naturally after we see the move king c1
we're going to be like oh that's loses
okay that loses to this move but this
you have this
and take all right guys excellent
excellent and at the end we'll do a
little
simpler solution a simpler one for you
at the end
this is not that difficult so compared
to other ones you should be able to
find this quite easily
all right white to play and win
the position of the king for black is
very passive and most incredibly the
bishop
bishop is misplaced okay
now the bishop if this pawn wasn't here
it would have been you know it
most ah actually if power wasn't there
maybe it's still a win with 96 but this
pawn
is causing a lot of problems okay
it's causing a lot of problems
what to do here
what to do to win this okay
no knight g6 is a is a problem he takes
and then he goes here and he has the
opposition
okay that doesn't work right here he
goes here
okay so we have to do something
different
by winning the f5 pawn you're not gonna
ensure ensure the victory okay
all right what's the idea
knight f3 correct he has to go to the
corner now now he wants to get out with
bishop g8 you don't want to let that
happen
so what are you going to do here so when
he goes bishop g8 you should have a mate
here guys
knight no knight g5 you let him escape
then it's going to be a draw yeah
you win this pawn but you're not going
to win you're going to sacrifice the
bishop for the last pawn
it's not about winning the pawn guys
it's about finding a way to
do a mating idea here
95 incredible correct if he goes here
simply knight g6 is a mate okay
so it has to go here and now
that's good because now at least we know
he's not moving the bishop okay
he's not moving the bishop
he's not moving the bishop what can we
do
now what's the idea knight d7
correct 97 you can play also you can
play
97 is one idea
what else what else you have besides
knight d7 what is the other idea you
have
knight c6 maybe do you have
anybody looking at knight c6 or not
knight c6 knight g6 is a draw
because every time you take the pawn
he's gonna get the opposition
so we go knight c6
now he goes here and now you want to
control the g8 square
how are you going to control the g8
square here guys
knight e7 controlling g8 if he goes here
knight g6 mate okay
cannot do anything and now
you basically box the king in the corner
here
if he wants to give up the bishop of
course you're not going to take with the
king it's going to be a still mate
it's going to take with this this
and this all right
so knight c6 is a win by the way your
you guys were suggesting 95 uh this line
95
knight d7 is also works but you have to
make sure you play here knight f8
hitting the bishop if he goes here you
still have a mate so this idea works as
well
so and if he goes king here you take
okay so both knight e5 knight c6 97
works which i like a little better
but also you can play knight d7 knight
f8 as well okay
yeah this bishop is simply trapped in a
corner okay
excellent job guys we had a great
turnout here
very active participants and you guys
did a great job today okay
on insane in the endgame class okay
i'm gonna back with you with two more
lectures
on thursday okay make sure you tune in
next uh this thursday guys for my
lectures
uh this is my final week so don't miss
it
uh that i'm working for the club doing
these lectures
so looking forward to seeing you
everybody on thursday okay
great job okay bye